[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum thank you for joining
us and sticking with the podcast if
you're here for Theo Rossi uh it's a
great interview I'm really excited about
it if you like it I'll ask as you
subscribe maybe write a review follow us
on our handles but uh subscribe and
listen to the podcast uh I hope you
enjoy it uh Ryan good to see you good to
see you too yep you had a great weekend
you saw a friend you needed it you
needed a little Ryan time the little
Orion time went to Washington DC
software nobody lives out there and had
a great little weekend I saw the Red Hot
Chili Peppers which I was not how were
they awesome was flea naked uh flee no
he was shirtless and wearing a kilt and
he did a handstand when he came out for
the Encore he walked out on his hands
you guys turning 60 this year did
underwear underneath yeah were they all
ripped up with the underwear no the the
frames they're frames yeah they're all
in great shape all the arms were showing
really yeah
nice chest nice chest great yeah all
right great body but he came out in like
a mess shirt and uh we took it we took a
bit like how how many songs before it's
off I said three songs tops it was gone
by the Yeah three songs exactly three
songs three songs boom this is when I
took my shirt off it's done I recommend
it they're they're torn around all right
I was never a massive like like a like a
super fan but uh great show great Rock
show I like that yeah I hope you guys
are doing well this week um thanks again
for watching listening uh you could
listen anywhere Apple podcast Spotify uh
YouTube you can watch make sure you
write a review our handles are Ryan uh
inside of you Pawn on Twitter at inside
of your podcast on Instagram and
Facebook that's exactly right
uh check out the inside you online store
we've got great stuff uh uh Smallville
Alexis script signed by me we've got um
Funko Pop Lex Luthor sign we've got
inside you merch hats and mugs and
tumblers and all that stuff so the
inside of you online store
also a reminder if you haven't check out
the new podcast talkville Tom and I Tom
Welling we talk about we watch every
episode of Smallville from the beginning
and we review it so that's airs every
Wednesday you could watch on YouTube or
listen wherever you get your podcasts
and uh Ryan we have a lot of fun doing
that as well we do
I'm learning a lot I'm learning a lot
about your past you are learning a lot
I'm learning a lot about my past yeah
um man well let's just do it I think we
can get right into it also just a quick
reminder to join patreon if you want to
support the podcast we need you we love
you top tier patrons get shout outs and
boxes of merch sent to them every couple
months there's different tiers anything
you want to help support the podcast it
really helps I'll send you a message
after
patreon.com
inside of you and without further Ado
let's get inside well you know him from
Sons of Anarchy but he's done a ton of
stuff he's got a new movie coming out we
talk about that but we really talk about
mental health and boy he opens up I love
this interview I remember it
distinctively distinctly either either
let's get inside of Theo Rossi it's my
point of view
of you listening to inside of you
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience dude you're doing all these
interviews you're all popular and [ __ ]
so silly and the fact that I'm like
third on your Sons of Anarchy list is
even more funny
third what do you mean I know you had
Flanagan coats I know you had these
people on well I know those guys I know
those guys it's irrelevant it's
Irrelevant in the grand scheme of things
I've already talked to hanum he's
Banning your show he's already said it's
not gonna happen that's it he's done
that's hilarious I like that you do the
research on me yeah
let's do it I gotta do the reason
like crazy you look good though I think
you're a natural beauty that's what I'll
say you know I'm a I'm a cover girl yes
I have the uh the natural Take Me Away
Calgon look uh
I remember the cat how old are you how
do you remember Calgon well I remember
everything I'm an 80s I'm an 80s freak I
watch in my down time like when I'm
filming this is like one of the weirdest
things that I've started to do over the
last couple years I just watch old
commercials from like the 80s and 90s on
four hour streams what's your favorite
one what's your favorite commercial or
one of you think one that you think of
thing to do with Toys R Us is like so
absolutely uplifting it's incredible
like when they're talking with Jeffrey
the draft because they're just having so
much fun
um max headrooms commercials what was
the Toys R Us theme song
I don't want to grow up um there's a
million toys at Toys R Us that I can
play with yeah it's amazing I mean how
does that not uplift your spirits it
really does because I'm playing these
like dark characters all the time and
like they're always in this horrific
place I try to balance it out by uh
watching commercials from the 80s and
90s I like watching old uh theme songs
from the 80s there was a show called
give me a break with Nell Carter give me
a break yeah I'm thinking a KitKat bar
but yes I watched that you watched give
me a break of course do you remember
it's probably around the same age I'm
50. oh okay so I'm three years younger
holy [ __ ] dude you look really good or
you have a filter on I don't this is it
it's I swear to God it's exactly the way
I look how do you look this young
I think I I've asked this question a lot
because you know I look at I used to
look at Ralph Macchio when I was younger
and I'd be like how is this guy looking
all young all the time
I think now now that I see my mom
because I was raised by my mom and like
she always looked young she's in her 70s
now and she looks like 50. and then I
think easy easy there she looks 50. what
are you saying 100 my mom looks super yo
so I think that it's because and she's
Middle Eastern right right and then my
dad was like Spanish and Italian and I
think that somewhere along the line the
genetics have to do it like the
Mediterranean thing or something but
also remember
I
completely like I don't
I guess I'm not like actively trying to
kill myself like a lot of people I know
like you know drinking smoking you know
what I mean yeah you don't do any of
that stuff
do any of that yeah wow you don't drink
do you drink caffeine I drink caffeine
yeah I do I have two two coffees in the
morning that's it I read that you were
you've been a vegan unless you've not
you're not a vegan anymore I I started
when I did true story I started eating
eggs because I was doing only like 600
700 calories a day I was doing this
weird thing and
I started eating eggs but I I'm off that
again so I did eggs for a minute but no
I don't eat anything like that maybe
that's what it is maybe the fact that
you don't eat meats you don't eat no no
no I you know what I no I don't think
any of that I think that
okay this sounds weird but I think that
like
to each his own right like what some
people can do
other people can't so you kind of can't
like look at what other people do like I
drink a ton of water but some people
don't like to do that it doesn't mean
that it's healthy it just means that it
works for me right like I
happen to when I'm not working
possibly partake in psilocybin a lot
right but that's just my thing right
it's Bill Simon what's so what's I
should know this it's uh shrooms yeah do
you micro dose or macro dose or what is
it
uh
the
maintaining of it is the micro that you
might call
it's something that uh I enjoyed but I
think it makes me
better right like as in the way I I
exist in this whole thing right not to
get all metaphysical and weird but it's
like this whole [ __ ] is like a minute so
when I get back to the health aspect of
it it's like what works for me
I don't think would work for someone
else like I run every day seven days a
week how far do you run between five and
eight miles
at 47 years old you're running this many
miles seven days a week I don't miss
is it is it an addiction they say it
takes 21 days to create a habit is it
something that that or is it just
something you just you just know now I
couldn't do it it's like I oh my camera
just got Buzzy hold on let me fix it now
you look even better Jesus I know how to
do it Jesus okay so here's my thought
I need it so whether it's an addiction
however they might put a label on the I
need it it's the only time I'm alone
crazy it's not crazy I this is part of
this podcast is to sort of dissect and
like get to know someone and what works
for them you know maybe someone out
there is listening going you know I'm
gonna try running five to seven I don't
know why you'd ever want to [ __ ] run
five or seven miles it sounds [ __ ]
awful but if it works for you yeah
it works for me and here's why
I have two kids I have an amazing wife
we live on a ranch in Austin it's
incredible we have a bunch of animals
and do all the things
but I get that time early early in the
AM to kind of reset and contemplate and
figure out all the things that
because your time gets bastardized the
second you get around a bunch of people
right like it just gets you things
happen right that breaks or this happens
or someone comes here or I have to talk
to this person so in that moment whether
it be five six seven eight whatever it
is the weekend I run longer
I know that I'm gonna get 40 whatever if
I'm doing an 8 30 Pace whatever that is
eight times five or six uh like 46
minutes
of pure peace for myself
if that makes perfect sense it really
does it's like you need that to check
into your day to get through the day you
need time for you
that's my meditation that's my that's my
so I figure out my roles when I'm doing
that I figure out my characters I figure
out how I'm gonna like the things that I
need to take on in the day
and and I'm also an extremely extremely
routine person that I've been for a long
time what do you do when you wake up so
besides what's the first thing you do
when you wake up
I can tell you the first thing I've been
I can tell you almost basically my
entire day for the last
I guess if I'm thinking about time
almost like 13 14 years even when I'm
working I will do a version of it when
I'm filming so the second I get up
um second I get up I handle the dogs or
you know whatever is going on the kids
are back to school so I usually have to
wake them up and I do that by playing
like
a song really loud and turning on the
lights so it's like either eye of the
tiger or something that's just 80s 80s
yeah 80s something might be uh she's a
little Runaway by Bon Jovi you never
know how old are your kids
five and seven so they're here in rising
up back on the street dad turn that
yes that's that's me coming up and they
usually are turning over one sleeps in a
tent he's been sleeping in a tent for a
couple of months I don't know why I
think I've been sleeping mother sleeps
in the bed in his room so there's a full
empty room
um
and then I play eye of the tiger or
today it was a
black clay today something by Journey I
think it might have been the one from
stranger things
um so I was playing something it gets
them up
then on a day like that
either my wife will take them and I'll
pick them up because I'm home from
filming I just got back
so we'll split either I'll pick them up
or she'll take them and then point is I
go right to run Now flip that
some days because I just got back I'll
go run a 5 30 in the morning or six so I
can get back and then wake them up right
I'll try to do it before it that's
that's preferable to me what time are
you going to bed at night
10 30. I'm out so you don't have that
much sleep six six seven hours
no I try to get seven or eight yeah six
seven yeah 10 30 10 o'clock I'm finished
all right so you go for the Run go for
the Run okay
back whatever happens with the kids
wherever at at that part of day and then
do you really want to go through all of
it do you want to be how nuts do you
want to see how nuts I am I mean kind of
just go go we'll do it okay this is
gonna get weird so then I I fill up I
have like a half a gallon of water that
I fill up I put in uh these uh these
minerals trace minerals and some uh
lemon
then I fill up two other glasses that
will be used later one is with
chlorophyll and one is with a little
apple cider vinegar and water it's mixed
and then uh I get to work that I'm doing
outside whether it be like right now
we're building a new chicken coop uh
we're building an enclosure for the
donkeys so I'll do something around here
with uh who's ever here with me right
and then I'll take the dog F now I'm
back from the run so me and Juno who's
right next to me sleeping she's wild
um she's like 100 pound shepsky she's
she's always with me she follows me
everywhere nice shepherd husky uh we go
on a giant walk around the property like
all around the ranch and uh we just
check in on everything seeing what's
going on then
sometime around noon I'll eat something
same breakfast every day complete
Insanity
I eat the same thing every day what
uh it's uh two pieces of Ezekiel toast
with almond butter
one
one apple
a bunch of different berries
potentially some watermelon when I was
doing eggs I was doing uh uh three eggs
right and uh
that's it
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
better help I don't know what we do
without better help uh you know I have
been lately dealing with a lot of
anxiety and what happens is I hyper
focus on all these negative things Ryan
that keep spiraling and I can't I can't
it's hard to focus it's and it exhausts
me and gives me anxiety
and these thoughts kind of just and I
know it's not I shouldn't be thinking
all these things and I it's like in my
mind I can't put it to rest a lot of
times
and um
you know it could be tough to to train
your brain to stay in problem solving
mode and you know especially when you're
facing challenges in life and I know
that therapy helps that talking to
someone and having them talk to you
objectively about what works train
professionals helps it just does I doing
it on my own isn't working it's just not
working
if I don't have someone to talk to I
will just continue to spiral there's no
way out that's how I feel
do you feel that way yeah
um you have to talk to somebody you know
people always say well how did you get
into therapy it's because I just
couldn't solve these problems on my own
I couldn't you know it's you could say
you're going to do these things and
you're saying oh you what happens is you
just bottle stuff up folks we just
bottle things up until it becomes very
toxic and our body feels it
physiologically we feel the effects of
you know pain depression anxiety and it
takes a toll on your mind and your body
and that is why I got into therapy and
I'll tell you A lot of times I have
nothing to talk about and for the first
five minutes like why am I here what am
I doing and by the end of it I'm like
thank God I'm talking to somebody my
Lord look if you're thinking of giving
therapy a try better help is a great
option Ryan here does better help it's
convenient accessible affordable and
entirely online get matched with a
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapists any time
um you know a lot of times people are
selling things and there's ads you have
to read to me this is the easiest read
ever because it's just something I could
talk about forever and
um look better help is is a great place
it's a it's a place to to help a lot of
people when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com inside today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at Magic spoon how many of
you have not tried magic spoon cereal I
don't know what to tell you other than
magic spoon is the goods can I say it's
the [ __ ] man
I'm going to it's the [ __ ] it's so good
I I always talk about this but you know
when you're a kid you drink eat all
these sugary cereals and you don't worry
about it because you're a kid but when
you get to be an adult all these things
become really bad for you but not magic
spoon you can enjoy cereal now that
doesn't have all the crap in it zero
grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein
only four to five net grams of carbs in
each serving low carb keto friendly
gluten-free grain free soy free and only
140 calories a serving you could build
your own box with a huge variety of
appealing flavors cocoa Frosty frosted
fruity peanut butter uh blueberry muffin
Maple waffle honey nut cookies and cream
cinnamon roll it goes on and on I mean
who doesn't love cereal the crunch
Ryan the sweetness the way you
accidentally eat a whole box or sneak it
as a midnight snack oh yeah that's what
we do uh Magic spoon
comes in it's got you know it has all
those things that you miss it's got that
sweet crunchy texture you love from
childhood but it's healthy it's healthy
magic spoon
has truly innovated and changed the game
with sugary cereals they spent time to
perfect the crunchy texture and develop
an outstanding an astounding variety of
flavors so that they always hit the spot
but without any of the things that are
so bad for you and it's packed with
protein and there's a flavor for
everyone you really need to try magic
spoon a lot of my friends have magic
spoon I love magic spoon here's what you
do
you go to
magicspoon.com
IOU to grab a custom bundle of cereal
and try the magic for yourselves and be
sure to use our promo code IOU at
checkout to save five dollars off your
order and Magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked I don't know
why why wouldn't you try something that
no questions asked I'll give you your
money back if you don't like it
give it a shot
right yeah well I love that stuff
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal
magicspoon.com
IOU and use the code IOU to save five
dollars off thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this podcast inside of you is
brought to you by Helix oh there's
nothing like a helix sleep I'll tell you
man mattresses are everything for me
I've had a lot of spine surgeries if I
don't get a good night's sleep if you
don't get a good night's sleep what are
we
or just what right zombies we're zombies
yeah not having a good night's sleep you
know people Overlook it they'll oh I
want a decent car I want to you know I
want to spend money on this but the the
most important thing
sleep
you gotta sleep on a good mattress and
Helix has the mattress for you they take
you take a quiz it's so quick and easy
but it tells them what's the right fit
for you
and that's it they have this quiz it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for someone else with Helix you're
getting a mattress that you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and Helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattress is
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot and even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers that's right I have a
medium mattress I'm like the porridge
guy I tell you here it's like I don't
want anything too too soft or too hard
something right there in the middle so I
could feel comfortable at night but
everybody's different some people like
the hard sleep the hard mattress but
again you just take this little quiz
trust me it's Rosenbaum you're talking
here it's an easy quiz it takes a minute
or two of your time and it tells you
what mattress is perfect for you it's
been awesome getting message from you
guys messages about Helix and how happy
you are with Helix that makes me happy
um I really love this uh this place this
company
so look if you're looking for a mattress
take the quiz order the mattress that
you're matched to and the mattress comes
right to your door shipped for free you
don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again oh those are just miserable
you like they all kind of feel the same
I I don't know I just uh Helix is
awesome but don't take our word for it
Helix was awarded the best number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 and
by GQ and Wired Magazine just go to
Helix h-e-l-i-x
sleep.com slash inside take their
two-minute sleep quiz and they'll match
you to a customized mattress that will
give you the best sleep of your life
tell us about the warranty Ryan they
have a 10 year warranty and you get to
try it out for a hundred nights risk
free they'll even pick it up for you if
you don't love it but you will Helix is
offering 200 off up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at Helix sleep.com slash
inside that's Helix sleep.com slash
inside for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
[Music]
like with what you're eating that gives
you enough energy for the day
yeah I'm weird like that I'm I've I've
read this thing many many years back
that said you know Eat to Live or live
to eat
and I just
I'm good even after I've done like I'm
good and the truth is
then I'll just like snack on like some
nuts or like raw nuts you know uh
throughout
I drink a lot of liquids and you feel
great you feel great all day every day
you feel great every day yeah I feel
great you never get any kind of I'm
taking it you never get any anxiety or
anything do you no
you don't deal with any anxiety no the
psilocybin helped that a lot it did
because I was thinking about I actually
am going to start micro dosing on on
shrooms yeah I can tell you everything
about it what do you need to know I'm
I'm well versed well I deal with a lot
of anxiety and I want to get out of my
head I want to be able to relax more I
want to be able to function more than
always in fight or flight mode and
everything's overwhelming and I want it
to stop I want those things to stop so
some people have recommended that my
friend Jessica and she made some
capsules for me and they're very very
low dose and you take one every three or
four days
does that sound about right
uh there's two different protocols I do
my own protocol there's a fatiman
protocol and a stamets protocol the
fatiman one that you believe is uh two
days on one day off
uh stamets is five days on two days off
mixed with some uh different vitamins
that you mix it with
um
I do my own
um meaning that there's different
strains right for different things you
want out of it but really it's all about
the intention now the first time I ever
did because I'm not counting when I was
an idiot kid right when I was an idiot
kid and I think this is where a lot of
people get tripped up you'll do like a
macro dose when you're you know when I
used to go to Limelight and I was like
15 and you do like
four grams of mushrooms and you're like
out of your mind right you're just like
playing Echo to dolphin with your
friends at like four in the morning and
feeling like you're in the game and
you're like what's what's happening here
that's not
that's not it that's that's not what
it's intended for right while might be
fun when you're a teenager it's
definitely not what it's intended for so
for me as someone who doesn't drink
doesn't smoke you know never really had
a great relationship with weed I tried
it wasn't for me
to go on the micro dosing Journey was
like
frightening because I was like wait a
second I don't know I don't know how
this is going to be and I don't know so
I researched it for a good two years I
started listening I read a bunch of
books Michael Pollan has a great book
out
um I should say I listened to books I'm
not sure anymore right yeah let's stop
let's stop trying to fool people
so I listened to a bunch of stuff I
would go on these YouTube vendors of
like seeing it and I was like well maybe
maybe right and then
um someone gave me some stuff that I was
like okay and like you said before
super minimal amount
and I did uh and a minimal amount is
um anything under 0.5 so anything under
0.5 of a gram is a minimal amount for me
right and and that after I did it I took
two months off uh where I went I need to
just process what just happened because
my entire
Earth was like off axis I was like what
just went on
where did my why did I feel all these
amazing things why was I questioning all
these amazing things
um it was almost like the way I
explained it to someone recently was it
was almost like someone woke me up like
they tapped me on the shoulder like hey
by the way take it easy it's okay and I
was like what what and then for two
months I had to process it that was
probably about
I don't know time is irrelevant with the
way the world's been the last two years
but probably about two years ago and
since then whenever I'm not filming and
for no particular reason people like oh
why don't you do it when you film it I
just don't just one of my weird habits
when I'm not filming
I
probably partake in it five of the seven
days a week and you feel like it calms
you it relaxes you it opens your what
are you feeling when it's working
it's changed your my whole life changed
everything nothing it you without
getting all weird because people get so
weird about that stuff it's like it's
not
the things that you are worrying about
while they're valid
they're ultimately irrelevant
like like you know what I mean like yeah
like we're like we're I've had a lot a
lot of people die and most horrifically
in my life whether it be through suicide
drug overdoses you know I had a lot my
birth father died when I was super young
my my uncle who was a big part of
raising me my thing is that we're gonna
die
and in a hundred years from now No One's
Gonna really know much right you know
it's gonna happen
and we're stressing about things that
the anxiety comes from a lot of these
things and this pressures that we put on
ourselves or that I could say I was
putting on myself and the truth is if
you look into
any type of really great literature like
Albert Camus absurdism and you study
stoicism and Marcus Aurelius and like
all these different deep rabbit holes go
listen to like
17 hours of Alan Watts you're gonna
understand that it's just
it's kind of pointless right like you
can't control the world I can't control
the world all I can do is control myself
and for me where I'm at now with these
two amazing kids an amazing wife an
amazing uh life that I'm trying to build
upon you know
of course there's still
demons around they're still like Egos
and people that are trying to you know
make my life harder and people that are
having a hard time and all that but what
am I going to do am I going to go to
Pieces about it am I going to go to
pieces if I didn't get
the job that I wanted or if it I just
have to keep moving and what it taught
me when you say what did it make me feel
it just made me kind of
make it all more granular where I was
like
this is silly
and
life is absurd
and I just I there's nothing I can do
about it the only thing I can do is take
care of myself and meaning like I can
only be the best version of myself for
you I can only be the best version of
myself right now for you for my kids for
my for Juno my dog next to me and I can
only worry about that
I can't control the rest of it
wow that really that's what happened by
doing this this is what opened your eyes
changing everything
changed everything because look this is
obviously you said it this is not for
everyone some people might go oh come on
your mushroom mush there's a science now
there's there's this is something that
people are really talking about in the
world and micro dosing and helping
people with anxieties and you know
there's there's the meds that you can
take there's the micro dosing there's
you know there's many different ways
to help with things and I think it's
just a process of elimination or seeing
what works for you you know um 100 do
the research Watch the watch the
documentaries on Netflix there's a
couple of great ones right
um a fantastic fungi and and watch them
and then make your own assessment but if
you
it I'm I think we're in a weird part of
like I guess this is something that I've
never done and I just don't do I Don't
Give opinions on anything because
opinions create adversaries I always say
all I can talk about is knowledge for me
and whether you agree with that I don't
give a [ __ ] there's nothing to do with
that yeah you know what I mean like I
just give you my knowledge from me if
you say well that's not true I'll go
okay it's true for me and so what what
does it matter what like you think but
we have come to this weird place where
everybody feels like their thing is the
right thing so that's why when people
ask me I go no no let me just tell you
what I do
and what works for me someone might hear
you eat the same thing every day and go
that's not enough nutrients that's not
enough this and I go okay
it works for me right like I'm so true
like I don't again
I've never been one to seek out like I
like to listen to people and I like to
hear their thoughts and then but like I
had to as I get older and you and I know
this it's like I started shedding away
the things that don't work for me and
the things that work for me so right now
you're saying you have anxiety that
you'd like to get past
okay
what Avenues are you going to try to do
that you can't just go one way you got
to try a month oh I'm trying a lot of
different things you're right you're
right I'm trying hypnotism I'm about to
start I'm trying energy therapy I'm
trying micro dosing I'm trying meds and
trying just trying to do everything
that I can to live the best life I can
and you're gonna find the one and it's
gonna be the thing for you and then
someone's gonna go what the [ __ ] would
you do that try this instead try this
try this go jump out of a plane wearing
a [ __ ] furry costume and you're gonna
like be way better and you go what I
know this works for me and that's
everybody has their thing and they think
they want people to come and believe in
it so it reassures that their thing is
the right thing and this is why what I
say I don't know people go oh you're a
vegan I go sure right now maybe not
tomorrow I don't I don't know and I
think that when you start
we want to box people so bad on things
on everything and I'm just like
I always say this and it gets people
weird I'm like I don't even exist like I
exist as in
when I'm a dad I'm with my kids when I'm
with my dog I'm Theo with the dog I'm
Theo as the dad I'm Theo talking to you
on this amazing podcast I'm it I'm Theo
when I see you at Comic Con like I'm
that per but I'm never who am I I'm I'm
just someone playing the role that I'm
in
so
I don't [ __ ] have I'm not I'm not my
feet aren't in concrete on anything
except one thing just don't be an
[ __ ]
simply don't be an [ __ ]
it's so much work it's so much more work
to be an [ __ ] isn't it and there's so
many of them have you worked with a lot
of [ __ ] [ __ ] yes
and it's not their fault it's the it's
this it's the system we that was built
upon what we've what we've created what
and then I say we not that I was Max
Senate or Charlie Chaplin or Daryl zanek
but I'm saying like the the system that
has been created has been
if you're talented you can do no wrong
um get away with murder
you get away with murder if you if you
sell box office
who gives a [ __ ] yeah do what you want
and they that has gone on and then what
happens is we give Awards to actors
when the actor
is is silent if there's no words from a
writer if there's no directions from a
director if there's no lighting from a
gaffer and there's no camera turned on
so it's like how about just give an
award for the entire project right
because once you start singling out
who's more important that starts
bleeding into the work environment
yeah
and it's completely ludicrous when you
think about it because if an actor was
the most important he can go stand alone
on a stage but nothing happening
laughs
I like how your mind works I'm
definitely micro dosing
you know we got deep a little bit we
started talking about micro dosing
everything there's a lot to talk about
and uh you know you've got Sons of
Anarchy and you know you're in Luke Cage
and you've done tons of movies and tons
of guest stars and you've been busting
your ass and working but by the way I
want to mention it this new movie you
have yeah Emily the criminal I watched
it now listen when they when your
publicist was like here's the link you
want to watch the movie I'm like oh [ __ ]
I don't have time to watch I'm gonna
[ __ ] movie right now what the [ __ ]
and I just started it I played it while
I was looking at some emails I'm being
honest with you and I was sucked the
[ __ ] in
I was sucked in it's so intense and
Aubry Plaza is brilliant and you're
brilliant in it and it's such a just
this crazy relationship that happens
between the two of you
and the movie is just like you feel for
I like movies when you feel for the lead
character who's doing the wrong thing
but you understand why she's doing it
and it's just this weird Journey that I
was honestly at times like in the room I
won't give anything away with the clock
ticking in the beginning I'm just like
oh my God and those characters you're
just like it's kind of it's a heist
movie it's it's it's much more than that
but I was really impressed with this and
people could watch Emily the criminal
where everywhere or everywhere it's in
theaters everywhere yeah Aubry and I uh
were just together we did our two
premieres in LA and New York we were
both kind of flying from other jobs in
and we got seen on the big screen
because we debuted Sundance but Sundance
went virtual uh last year
and really cool we were the highest
rated film out of Sundance you know it
was this little movie that you know I
mean we shot in 21 days that we just
didn't not that we didn't expect
anything Aubry produced it it was kind
of this thing that I was doing this
other movie in Atlanta and her and I
zoomed and it was like yeah like I when
when I see because I produced some stuff
like when I see someone putting it all
out there and I read this script it's a
90 minute movie you know it's a fast
read on the script and
I like movies that I call like
replacement Theory like where I can
watch it and go what would I do if I was
that person what would I do if I was in
that situation those are my favorite
movies like the game with Michael
Douglas oh yeah yeah yeah you know what
would happen here and it's when I watch
films and I read films like that I'm
like that's what I want to do I want to
I want to go on that ride it's like a
Six Flags ride and
her and I just you know when it debuted
Sundance it had a ton of buzz you know
like I said highest rated one we were
just waiting for it to come out
roadside's amazing
um we're in like I think we're in like
500 theaters now across the country
which is really cool
um it did really well it's the highest
critical thing I've ever been a part of
um
in all ways she's extraordinary in it
yeah extraordinary both you guys yeah
and you just want people you know John
Patton Ford first time director
um great job yeah just amazing so
it's been a really cool like run the
last few years and I feel like this was
the one that I was
I'm really excited about this one
because it's again a wildly different
character that I've been playing yeah
you guys have to say it Emily the
criminal I mean it really is good trust
me I was if you could write into me you
could write on the patreon yeah and you
could tell me what an [ __ ] I am but
you're I'm not wrong in this one this
was a movie that I was just emailing
while I'm listening and watching and
then I just got sucked in I'm telling
you and there was no turning back it was
just great performances intensity uh
just a really good story and you care
about the characters which is which is
hard to do
yeah I mean you know it's that anti-hero
thing we've been doing since like you
know uh uh Vic Mackey and the shield and
you know obviously a bunch of things
where you start to like the villain I
think we've probably been doing it a lot
longer than that it's just been you know
kind of more uh uh Amplified with
television yeah right you know speaking
of we were just talking about this the
other day my buddy and I it's like and
you you know you obviously taking on one
of the most legendary characters in
history in Lex Luthor but I talk about
Gene Hackman and when he played Lex
Luthor it's like I liked him way more
than Superman when I was a kid I knew it
yeah I don't know why I just did so I've
been better even better to watch yeah
right that's not supposed to happen but
then if you look at the Godfather and
stuff like that we identify more where
we go oh because they're you know
they're I'm probably gonna say the word
wrong but they're they're fallible yeah
they're
where would with superheroes or good
characters I don't mean in the literal
sense of the cape when you're the good
character the the straight you know lace
you can't
have anything wrong with you where the
the one who's a little
uh ambiguous has more things going on
there's and that's life we're all
you know the yin and the Yang of life so
so I think that with Emily
that's the service of what John created
where you go I know these people are
doing something wrong but I gotta tell
you I kind of like them I know it's just
so weird when that happens it's it's a
little magic because usually you know
films a lot of the movies I watch I just
feel like you know if you don't start
out with them in a movie at least liking
someone or someone is engaging or
there's you just it doesn't matter how
good the movie is in terms of like you
know story and whatever you've got to
somehow connect with these characters if
you're going to go on this journey I
feel anyway a lot of times yeah and that
it doesn't happen
do you ever find let me ask you a
question because you've met a ton of
people in this business do you ever find
that like if you don't like someone you
can't watch them anymore
uh yeah I'm not gonna make any say any
names but there's some people I'm like I
just can't look at that person I can't
believe that person I can't hear that
person I know and it's probably shallow
of me but it's just it's it's a gut
reaction
it's a gut reaction it's a gut reaction
don't you ever meet somebody in person
in real life and then just go I just I
don't like that person all right I would
never hang out with that person that's
the same thing
I I equate it to like the animals that
I'm around all the time and like
especially my dog like she just either
likes you or she doesn't right she knows
she just knows like she'll be like wait
a second or she just goes bananas like
throws it at you and like she's on you
right I feel that way around certain
people I'm like and you can call it
energy you can call it whatever you want
but you go uh not for me yeah and then
it's on the flip where if I meet someone
and they're like amazing I can't wait to
watch their stuff I'm like oh man I'm
gonna watch everything that person's in
because they were such a great person
and that's the weird thing about this
business because you meet some people
in stuff that you used to like and
you're like oh I can't watch that
anymore I know it's yeah I know it's a
shame it's a shame sometimes you meet
people and they're just not what you
thought and you're like oh my God and
then yeah you can't go back and watch
them yeah we don't have to get into the
names but yeah but you know look I'm
Awesome on the movie Emily the criminal
you guys gotta see it please check it
out it's really freaking good but you
know we were talking about all these
good things how you have your [ __ ]
together how you have this routine you
got your family you love your family and
your dog and you got this Ranch and it
seems like life's going great for you
knock on wood I always knock on wood I
don't know if that works where's wood
well it works for me see it works for me
we were just talking about that Theo
okay hold on there you go
we're in yeah thank you
um but it wasn't always
rainbows for you no I mean you grew up
with a single mom your dad wasn't around
what what explain that story like
growing up
super weird I guess in the 80s of
I was the first person that I knew that
there
father wasn't living in the house like
he was gone and like everyone was aware
of it and again this is probably around
19
I mean totally aging ourselves here
let's see I was nine so
84 84. and I remember thinking like
huh
but I was you know and again they tried
to like pull the you know oh he's just
moving closer to work I was like he
works like a mile and a half away was he
wasn't gonna move closer for it takes
five minutes to get there but I was more
rational where my sister was like oh
that makes sense he'll get there in a
minute and I was like okay but I knew
you know you always knew here's the
thing everybody goes through it he was
he was a person
and I could say this now that you know I
found out he died on the internet in
2010 and I only found that out because I
went out and searched looking for him
after the success of Sons of Anarchy
um
because I'd been written up in the local
paper in New York and I was like maybe
the time is now because the last time we
had a conversation was
um when my uncle his brother had killed
himself and I had to call and tell him
because he didn't know and I hadn't
talked to him in years and the
conversation did not go well and
here's the thing he was a guy who was
not supposed to be a father
there's a very big difference right this
is why I always tell people if you're
contemplating having kids
once you have children
it's them
your whole existence is into them it
doesn't mean that your life stops it
means your life changes and if you still
are embarking on an ego journey and it's
all about you well you're doomed because
now you're going to become resentful
you're going to start acting out of
character you're going to do things now
this is back in the time when they
didn't have the resources the tools to
talk like we are now to have
conversations it just was well I don't
want to do that I'm doing I'm doing this
I didn't fulfill these things I wanted
to do
he had gotten around some you know
unsavory characters he was an unsavory
character himself and he just wasn't
meant to be a father
my mom was super young and uh he was
gone and that was it and what that did
for me now that I can look back on it
while it was
hectic it brought every
thing in my life because it gave me like
a bit of a chip on my shoulder
and it kind of made me it put me in
scenarios of like working and
different thoughts and like what I that
I needed to succeed and I needed to do
something different I want to turn out
like him and there were times where I
was gonna be like him and there were all
these different things that I had
learned
from that lesson
so as I grow older I look back on it and
it was tumultuous I mean I remember at a
young age
um
there are a lot of weird things that
happen now that I look back when I talk
about it with my mom sometimes I mean
there was a time where the FBI came and
raided my house and they were looking
for my dead grandmother because
everything was put in her name
um there was
all these strange occurrences of like
you know waiting sitting on the stoop
where he's supposed to come and get you
for the weekend and he never shows right
it's like it's like out of a movie I was
just gonna say that that's like wow it's
like out of a movie and then when they
do show there were times when they did
Show when he was hammered and like you
know you're in this car and you're like
I'm gonna [ __ ] die on this thing and
all of that stuff starts to play into
who you become and you're going to go
one way or the other and I've definitely
gone all the ways you know as as the as
the Macho Man Randy Savage once famously
said I've soared with the Eagles and
I've slithered with the snakes and
everything in between right yeah but you
got to keep moving forward it's like all
those things leave Impressions on your
brain and you start to grow up really
fast so I started doing things
at a super young age that
I'm happy now because they made me who I
am
but as having two young kids I'm like
that was too young that was too young to
do those things I think but again I
don't know right it just I know life is
what it is so I was around I was all
women right my my sister my mom my nana
you know I was around all women and it
was amazing it's an incredible way to be
raised because I was able to
have the toughness of where I grew up
and have the the the I should say the
the the smarts the fragility the smarts
and the and and the the intestinal
fortitude and tenacity of the women who
are around me and
I think that that prepared me for life
and I think that I my mom was an artist
she's a dressmaker my
birth father before he even though he
led a extremely criminal lifestyle was a
really wonderful artist
um a great designer was was very smart
but again never almost like Yusuf in
Emily the criminal never he wanted more
but he was thrust into this life right
um
and that was just the beginnings but
then I went through you know I did all
the typical you know hectic stuff of
figuring out who I was I just got really
fortunate that I figured it out
uh before I was too old
did you get pretty deep into things
because I know you came out with openly
to say that you were dealing drugs and
things like that were there times where
you could have died many times
I've been in some really precarious
situations let me fix this camera I was
in some precarious situations meaning
that
I didn't know any better I was I was not
equipped
for
I was not okay so if you're if you're
from a family of lawyers
you kind of yeah we're gonna you're
gonna be a lawyer or you know military
families a lot of guys follow or women
following the footsteps of their father
and join you know and go down range and
join so you're kind of raised by the
thing around you so when there's no one
there
when the goal is survival
you figure it out and for me
when it came to you know hustling and
dealing drugs and doing whatever I was
doing it was just because it was the
only thing I knew how to do I always say
that no criminal wants to do crime they
just do it because they don't really
[ __ ] know what else to do right no
one's giving them another uh Avenue and
and then you go well you can go work
here I remember that I remember when I
went to go try and work at Blockbuster
my freshman year in college and they
were like okay so you have to wear tan
pants go get those I was like I don't
have any money to get 10 [ __ ] hands
and then they were like okay and you're
gonna get I think back then it was like
275 an hour and I was like 275 an hour
I could flip an ounce and make 600 why
would I do that it sounds ridiculous
because again I just always thought of
life in time so this scenario was never
like oh yeah but you're not going to go
to jail for [ __ ] putting away fast
times in Richmond High the wrong way I
wasn't thinking that when I was doing it
right it was it was just
it was just
I can do this and that seemed more
reasonable
yeah and there was no one there going
it's not reasonable let me tell you why
it was just me and my own brain and the
people who are around me who had the
same mindset as me and we're going yeah
[ __ ] it let's just let's just flip some
let's go grab 20 pounds and do this and
you go oh cool because it made more
sense so again I think it's what your
your what's in your tool kit what do you
have for you and I didn't have I had
different
set of skills as they would say I didn't
have the right set of skills maybe I
guess in
societal terms but I learned them yeah I
learned the moment what got you out of
it though what what what happened that
life took a different direction because
a lot of times you get you go down that
path and that's a lot of times people
can't get can't come back from that
there's always a moment everything's a
moment there's always a moment like when
I stopped even drinking and doing
anything there's always a moment there's
a moment that something happens someone
says something that you go oh
and for me when that happened I had
been in a situation where
I basically got brought in by the cops
for something
and
when I and I got let go for a reason
might have known a few people and when I
got home
to keep this story as shallow as
possible when I got home
I realized that I could have been in a
lot more trouble for what I might have
had on me that wasn't found and I
realized like when I jumped out of a
plane once
that I'll never do it again you can only
spit in God's face so many times right
so it's like I knew at that moment I had
to make a decision that I was like okay
I'm okay I'm here
if I do this again I might not be
so what's what's the choice what am I
gonna do
am I gonna go again
and roll the dice
or am I going to stop and figure out
something else
most people can't make that decision it
can't stop you think that that's how
it's a hard decision to make that you
were you had enough foresight or
whatever that you you sort of just
understood in a mature way
weirdly mature that I'm gonna this is
not gonna end well
it was it was the first time I'd ever
really looked at the ramifications of it
right it didn't mean that it fully
stopped then either it means that at
that moment that was a stop to the next
part right and it was like every and
then
even when I got to La I only knew
certain skills right so like I only knew
certain things I didn't have
skills Beyond labor right like I just
and and I considered that you know
hustling like labor I just only knew
yeah I was either gonna go work a
construction site or bartend or bar back
or deal drugs like that that was it I
did that was the extent of my resume in
life like I just didn't if you told me
oh we're gonna go you know lay rugs in a
building like I used to do on the
Summers sure I can do that but I only
had a limited
I didn't have many skills so when I
looked at that one skill at that time I
went I can't do this I got to figure
something else out
so I figured something else out at that
moment but then sometimes you have to
revert back to the only skills you know
have you you know have I remember in
2000 oh God you were probably in LA in
2000 and uh
2 3 2003 2002 I was working in a
restaurant in a bar
I booked a co-star recurring I didn't
know the difference I thought once I got
a recurring on the show Boston Public
that I was going to be this is it
see you later
Rob Lowe here I come I'm coming for the
cover of People magazine like this is it
and then and then uh that ended after
three episodes and I was like wait I
just quit my job like I was like wait I
thought this was it again I didn't have
the skill set so I had to figure it out
how was I going to keep pursuing what I
wanted to do because this was a time
when back in the day you used to have
six auditions a day you'd have
commercials you'd have guest stars you'd
be learning stuff in the car and I had
to figure it out and my buddies at the
time had opened up uh an after hours and
it was in liberace's Old penthouse on
Beverly Boulevard and it opened at 11 uh
two in the morning and he closed at like
11 in the next day oh my God I was the
only bartender in there
and uh
I saw some [ __ ] in that place
what'd you say
can't talk about it it was wild
it was wild I want you to Imagine This
it was only like Word of Mouth
and it was in liberace's Old penthouse
and
it was all famous people
doing and I was the only bartender and
they were like two Waiters
so you saw snorting and drugs and sex
and boobs everywhere and dogs wildest
[ __ ] I've ever [ __ ] like I would
literally go to my friends and go did
you [ __ ] see who's in that room and
you see what's going on over there did
you see this did you see what's
happening by the pool like it was
insane as a young kid who was so
enamored by Hollywood
it was it was like someone brought you
behind the wizard curtain and I was like
what the [ __ ] is this big actors you're
talking big A-list actors
I'm talking like Oscar winners I'm
talking like I'm talking like the
biggest of the big from music to acting
to everything and I was like holy [ __ ]
this is the craziest [ __ ] I've ever seen
this is like I I don't understand how
and and all through the night right two
days and how much are you making how
much are you making in a night like tons
tons of money because I was I was so I
had such a like a hustle attitude my my
thing was if you now remember most
people are geeked out of their face if
they want to get a drink from me
they have to give me a lot of money
because I'm the only one working
so they're peeling off like hundreds
just because the alcohol is free
which they used to you know do that [ __ ]
where they'd fill up the Gray Goose
bottles with like the you know the the
uh whatever pop off like the shittiest
right yeah and then and then you they
would say oh I want I want the Gray
Goose here's 300 and you're like okay
sure sure it's Gray Goose let me just
put a lot of soda in it and they would
get so I would make uh I was making a
couple of thousand for two days wow at
least yeah that's insane
and then I'd have my whole week off
for auditioning that's beautiful
what a damn treat you know it lasted
like two years
um I look at your like
resume and like
you did so many guest stars I mean Law
and Order Hawaii 5-0 the unit Jericho
bones without a trace Veronica Mars NYPD
Blue CSI I mean it goes on and on don't
forget lost that was lost I love lost
yeah I mean you you you're in everything
I mean was it so this is what you I
guess this is like during the 2000s
early 2000s
and so what was the The Big Break was
was The Big Break Sons of Anarchy that
was the big first I'm a regular on a
show yeah I did I did two pilots that
never got picked up one was a sitcom and
one was uh
one was I guess like kind of like a
Gray's Anatomy rip-off they didn't go
and I was Mr guest star there was a
there was a time where I was doing a
movie in New Orleans and there were
three guest stars Aaron at the same day
three different networks that I'd done
on like a Wednesday at 8pm and my mom
was like which one do I watch I was like
I don't know CBS ABC NBC I was on all
three
and it was one of these weird things
where I was doing a lot of guest stars
on a lot of commercials
and when Sons came
Sons is a strange story I auditioned for
every single Roland Sons like when I say
every role I started with Jax I went
down the line and I didn't get anything
and Wendy uh O'Brien who is the casting
out there just casts uh cast me in two
things one was a show medical
investigation with Neil McDonough that I
did like a guest spot on and she loved
and one was this Chris Carter movie that
never came out called Bellflower
um Chris Carter creator of the Xbox oh
yeah yeah she she was championing for me
on Sons but I didn't get it and I was
like and it was a weird time in my life
because my uncle Who was the the single
most biggest influence on me to this day
he moved to North uh Northern California
when he was 21 when his when my
grandfather died he left New York
and he became like a bit of like a biker
he was a rockabilly biker and then he
worked at San Quentin and then he got
caught stealing drugs and he went into
San Quentin as a prison like it was like
this whole crazy story and he was the
most colorful human being I'd ever met
in my life
and he would sit there while we would go
for walks when I was in New York and he
would just talk to me about these
motorcycle clubs
and he would give me like the history of
him and he this is years before
so I was under the impression that sons
was like my destiny because he died in
o4 when I was doing this movie and uh
Toronto had found out he died at the
wrap party so I was like oh
I'm supposed to do this show
but I didn't get it
and then about a week later I got a call
from Wendy O'Brien she said hey uh Kurt
the Creator wants to talk with you and I
was like okay she's like just just talk
to him he he has an idea for something I
was like okay and he's really short with
the way he talks and he goes uh listen I
don't know if you'll be in one episode
or a hundred I don't know if you'll have
one line or a hundred I I don't know I
just want you on the show and I was like
okay he's like but we don't have any
money and like it like but I just want
you on the show and I was like okay
so I went back and I was testing for
another pilot at the time and I told my
uh manager at the time
um they left me after this
um I said I'm gonna do that show and
they're like no you're not it's like
zero dollars you're testing I said no no
I'm gonna do that chip
and I did and uh I got made irregular in
the second season and uh my entire life
changed I met my wife through it my
whole life and my whole existence you
met your wife on set
no when I went over to Iraq and Kuwait
uh Baghdad like we did all the Uso tours
right
my wife uh she was a former news anchor
and she was um doing PR for military
Charities she started with Marcus
Luttrell on them and then she was doing
stuff for the boot campaign and we met
through that and um
a couple years later we kind of met you
know again and now we have two kids and
we live in a ranch in Texas so again it
all came from like everything else like
all my other jobs came from Sons and
came from that moment of like Wendy
taking a chance and Kurt taking a chance
and me taking a chance yeah how would
you sum it up like if you had to sum up
Sons of Anarchy for all those years you
did it
I mean it was probably grueling schedule
and a lot of work right absolute chaos
but I have it no other way it was
like Charlie and I just said when we did
that Reaper review thing with Kim and I
it was like going to college like for me
I had been around I was around these for
me again I'm like a
I love character actors I it's weird
because I would think all actors are
characters but whatever I love character
actors and I think it's like when I saw
Ron Perlman and Kim Coates and Tommy
Flanagan and Katie Seagal and like and
and I did the original pilot with Scott
Glenn like who I'd done who had done a
movie with prior to that I was
enthralled I was also a giant fan and a
shield so I was like so happy to be
there
um
chaos it was absolute chaos I when I did
Luke Cage right after it I had the same
executive producer writer who was on
that show with me and it was a also the
showrunner I had done this movie I did
lowriders he wrote that I was almost
like um
I Rescue all my dogs and so I know what
it's like I was like a dog who just got
rescued but they were like hey hey it's
okay it's okay they just need you on set
like it's okay because it was like I was
so tense all the time from Suns all the
time really just tense with wanting to
be great wanting it to work what was it
it was like a heavy show like it was
Heavy in all aspects it was
I I could talk about the positives for
days like I don't know what it's like to
be in the Rolling Stones or the Beatles
or being like a rock band like even a a
minimal one
but like when we were together and we
were together all the time on our bikes
going to comic-cons going to restaurants
going to bars it was like being rock
stars like you would just roll up 11
deep and everyone was in the show and
people were like what the [ __ ] is
happening here so it was that where it
was like I'd never been exposed to that
I was a guest star actor and then at the
same time it was the schedule of the
amount of we were filming on the budget
we were filming it would be compared to
like a low budget Indie now and we were
filming at a at an accelerated pace
and then the emotions were running so
high
so we would we had no other choices but
to well I know for me and maybe it's
because I'm not nearly as good as an
actor as all the other people I had no
other choice but to exist as that
character all the time
because of the schedule
wow so and Juice was like a really
[ __ ] up character so I was kind of
[ __ ] up for like eight years
really it messed you up for eight years
you were just kind of like not quite
yourself
I tried to turn it off but it was like
we were always all together so our
Dynamic was shaped from the show
wow so it was like you were you were
emulsified into who you were so it was
like you you almost had to take it on
because it was so
all the time all the time you're always
reminded like all the time right you
have a especially when you have a mohawk
and tattoos on your head like you can't
you're that guy you can't get away from
it you can't get away from it which is
an amazing thing
and it really I think like Charlie and I
said the other day I don't think you can
ever do that again it was like a it was
like a moment in time right it doesn't
exist anymore it's like The Sopranos I
talk to those guys and they had a lot of
the same exact kind of deal where they
were just together all the time to go to
dinners all the time and their
characters kind of acted like their
characters
do you still talk to all the guys all of
them all the time all the time just what
a Brotherhood that's crazy I just got
off with Kim I just got off with coats
uh I was texting with Pearlman I love
them I love I I we it was like um
it's like we went now we can reflect on
it
like now but it was like we went through
this thing that we were all unsure of at
the end and we just needed to get away
from each other
and then we came back around I think
that happens I think that happened even
with me and my co-star Tom uh yeah we
were we were you know we were really
cool but the last thing you want to do
is hang with people that you're on set
with all day for all those years and
then a couple years passed and then it
just sort of a friendship evolved you
know kind of respect and respect a
mutual respect it was really weird and
like we we do things together we you
know it's it's nice um this is called
[ __ ] talking with Theo Rossi uh this is
my top tier patrons they ask questions
you answer rapidly if you'd like if for
some reason you want to talk about it
yeah go to patreon.com inside of you I
appreciate all the love I'll send you a
message if you join and thanks for the
support of the show here we go Sophie M
what is something you wish you knew now
that you didn't know when you started
acting uh don't give a [ __ ] what anyone
says hmm God I wish I could live by that
Dana s what is in your music playlist
besides eye the Tiger
uh my music taste is all over the place
um usually it's uh mellow folk music at
this point
um that's what I hit on the uh Amazon
but I've become rapidly obsessed with
this Elvis movie and the soundtrack that
bass put out
I love Elvis that movie was good I like
the movie he was extraordinary he was
extraordinary extraordinary baz's mind
is extraordinary the soundtrack if you
get the one that he did he explains the
songs and it's in a certain order and
it's curated the right way is
extraordinary
um but I listened to to to answer more
specific I've been listening to a lot of
John Prine lately I haven't listened to
enough of him
it's really good all right
uh Danny What attracted Theo well what
it attracted you to Emily the criminal
fantastic chemistry with Aubry Plaza
well you told him you pretty much told
us
yeah I had never seen her in anything I
tell her this all the time I had not
seen her the oh the only uh film that I
had watched her work in without even
knowing it was this Christmas film that
I think was on Netflix
but I had not watched parks and recs I
had not seen black bear I'd seen them
all now
um I had not seen Ingrid Goes West and
it's just for the lack of like the last
seven years with kids has just been you
know I watch you know Wreck-It Ralph
every five minutes so it's like I know
what I mean ask me about Coco I'll tell
you everything but I just didn't know
about the other stuff so but when I got
on the zoom with her and John
that she was easily the reason really
yeah she's a legend she's I I tell her
she's uh I've never seen
it so you know we're in such a weird
time right
650 television shows 950 movies last
year we don't like what she's doing is
extraordinary
she's hysterical yet
I could just name three movies that is
some of the best dramatic performances
I've ever seen Emily being the best of
them maybe black bear
that's such a rarity I can only name
very few actors Phil Hoffman comes to
mind and Robin Williams and people that
do drama and comedy seamlessly you know
and she is doing that there's just a
very few and I know of course
everybody's like yeah but not at that
level of course give her a moment yeah
just you know but it's like when you're
doing that
seamlessly when you're funny
and you're knocking it out of part
dramatically I mean we got to stop and
pause for a second and say that's a
rarity yeah there are certain actors
that I absolutely I love Daniel
Day-Lewis but hasn't made me laugh
recently you know what I mean it hasn't
made you laugh ever
well no I actually did find him pretty
funny as build a butcher he's pretty fun
oh yeah yeah for sure uh what was it
called New York uh
Gangs of New York Yankees in New York uh
you know Megan T says what type of
character do you love to play and on the
other hand which one do you hate to be
type as in other words I would say what
do you want to do what would you like to
do
what kind of role
I just wanna at this point I just want
to work with good people like I like to
me like the character I'll
create whatever's in there I'll make it
something
whatever because you could always find
something in a character you know what I
mean like obviously you want great
writing but
you can find something at this point
because I'm so aware of how short life
is
I just want to work around good people I
don't want to be in those like tense
weird situations of like
[ __ ] I gotta avoid this person and this
person shows up three hours late or
[ __ ] this has happened like it's like
I just don't have time for that [ __ ]
like I'm I'm you know to quote Brian Cox
recently like you know the great Brian
Cox he said uh uh I'm too old I'm too
tired and I'm too talented [ __ ] off
you just don't have the time so it's
like I just want to work with really
great people character-wise um you know
uh you can make anything
three-dimensional you can make you know
that's why when people say oh do you
play a lot of bad guys I'm like bad to
who
to the viewer not to me I don't think
they're bad guys right you know you know
or if you say don't you want to play
like good guys with it sure whatever
I love it got such a good attitude
damn you Theo I need to listen to Theo
in the morning I need him to make a
recording for me that I could listen to
every morning and before I go to bed
give me some confidence give me some
perspective on life hey you know I'm
gonna ask you I hate to end on a downer
but I keep thinking about it that that
when you when you were looking up your
father yeah uh
you know because you had all the success
and then when you found out he had
passed what kind of emotions happened I
mean have you have you learned to
forgive him have you have is that yeah
yeah that's a great question it's not a
downer either at all I mean um when it
I'll never forget it was 2010
it was my last year of smoking
cigarettes I was smoking an American
Spirit on this porch
on Los tilos the tapa Outpost I had this
really cool I called it the Batman house
and it was like overlooking all of
Hollywood and I couldn't sleep and I
went on the computer
and my my cousin who was a cop in New
York I had written him and said how do I
find this dude like what do I do and
he's like oh man it's all public records
and I was like what he's like yeah just
go on this you know pay 40 or whatever
it is you get everything you need to
know I was like oh cool because his
number's not working
he was out of service or whatever and um
I'll never forget I was sitting on that
porch I had three dogs at the time they
were all with me and I was smoking
American Spirit and I was scrolling on
the computer and I had paid for whatever
it was but I don't even know if it still
exists public records.com or whatever it
was and I was scrolling through and it
showed all the addresses and the arrests
and this and I was like oh yeah it's
definitely him right and I got to the
bottom and it said uh died
September 29 2009 and I was like
what no
and I refreshed and I was like wait a
second maybe I got the wrong one but
then it was his birthday it was
everything was right
so for a minute I kind of like
it's you know it's a gut punch in the
beginning but then it was like oh
[ __ ] okay
okay
and
it was a test for me because I had just
gotten my life to a certain place where
I was either gonna go that way and I was
gonna go back that way and this was one
of those things I said which way are you
going to go now
where you gonna go and I was like okay
and here's what I'll say about the whole
situation
not just have I I've never had to
forgive him I don't need to forgive
anyone I don't need to forgive anyone
and I I know it's not part of my thing
people do what they do
I'm closer to him now
than I ever was
however that is relatable to other
people it might not be it might be it
only matters for me
I speak to him see him talk to him and
have a way better relationship than I
did in the
however many years we didn't talk
however many the little things that I
remember from when I was young but now
in the research in the going back
I got it all
that's amazing
that is truly amazing yeah uh this has
been eye-opening
I really love your your attitude I mean
you've been around the block you've kind
of been you've experienced all these
different emotions and and what life
throws at you and
you've you've ended up in such a
positive great place and I couldn't be
happier for you it's uh it's tremendous
man it's tremendous dude it really is
and uh well what you're doing is
tremendous I I really do I appreciate so
much what you're doing and I think that
you know at the end of the day what I
love about everything that's happening
and more importantly what you're doing
is like conversation is the key to all
right like at the end of the day
being able to just speak and talk the
one thing that it shows everyone is how
similar we all are we just let people
speak we start to realize how similar we
all are but when it's happening in 140
characters faceless no you know whatever
that's when it shows more differences
and I think that conversations like this
even if you relate to one two three
things
it just shows that we're all part of
this thing and more importantly like
it's all going to be over in a [ __ ]
blink so what you're doing
it's just cool like you know whatever
whatever everybody wants to think it's
just really cool so I appreciate it uh
more than you know I appreciate you man
thanks for coming on the podcast uh I'm
gonna ask your publicist for your email
because I have to yeah everyone just
checking whenever you want to talk
whatever you need to know I'm I will
give you whatever ridiculous knowledge
remember I'm south side of an idiot on
most things but some things I have some
knowledge I love it hey thank you so
much for coming on the podcast thanks
for allowing me to be inside of you uh
you're so much better than Kim and um I
know I'm kidding you guys were great you
guys were all great
um this has been awesome dude have a
great day and thanks for uh thanks for
being here man I appreciate you brother
enjoy your day all right buddy
what can you say
um I want to hang out with that guy I
think I I have actually texted him since
the interview just say hey what's up man
just thinking you know and he responded
just loved loved him and uh how open he
was I was so surprised you never know
when you don't know someone and you
interview them Ryan you're like how deep
are they gonna get how open are they
gonna be are they going to be talkative
are they going to be or are they going
to be a dud and he was more
then
anticipated let's just say that so uh
thanks for supporting the podcast guys
thanks for everything thanks for joining
patreon if you're a patron patreon.com
uh inside of you I want to say talk
though because we have one there too but
uh Patron really helps the podcast so
much we wouldn't do this without the top
tier without all the patrons who give
back to the show I don't care if it's a
dollar or whatever it's like something
that you know helps pay for [ __ ] and uh
thank you for listening hopefully um
you'll listen uh continue to listen here
are the shout outs
for our wonderful patrons top tier
patrons get a shout out here they are
Nancy D Leah s Sarah V little Lisa
Yukiko Jilly Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie M Kristen K Raj C Joshua
D cjp Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F
Janelle B Kimberly Mike e l Don Supremo
99 more Ramirez Santiago M Chad W Leanne
P Janine R Maya P Maddie s Belinda
n correct
um this is a random
Chris H David Sheila G Brad d Ray H
Tabitha T Tom and Liliana a Talia C no
M okay Betsy D correct Chad L Marion Dan
and big Stevie W Angel M Rhiannon c
chord K devnex and Michelle a Jeremy C
Andy T caffeinator deep see John B
Brandy D Camille s the chief Joey M
design
OTG Eugene and uh Leah correct Nikki G
Corey Katie B Heather L Jake B Megan T
Mel s Orlando C
uh Caroline
I've already forgotten R okay Christine
s Sarah s Eric H Shane r m r Jeremy V
Andrew M
zetuichi 77 Oracle Chris R Michael F
Karina n Michelle D Amanda R Amanda s
Jen B Kevin e Katie red and Stephanie k
I don't know what I would do without you
patrons thank you again and thanks for
listening um
you know I'm trying to get over the the
anxiety I'm still dealing with it I feel
like it's a little better
you just have to keep trying you have to
keep trying different meds and you have
to keep you know exercising I'm doing
hypnotherapy and really trying to battle
this
you kind of have to do a lot all at once
it's not just one easy fix isn't it no
it's not an easy fix it's uh
it's the toughest thing I've gone
through I think in a while a long while
I think the biggest thing I've gone
through it's just like trying to get
back on track and I feel like you know
you just got to keep working therapy
therapy therapy exercise
and uh be good to yourself most like
most importantly
um thank you guys again for listening uh
from the Hollywood Hills and Hollywood
California I am Michael Rosenberg hi
Brian Tans
we love you guys thanks for tuning in
and always remember to be good to
yourselves I will see you very soon
thank you
[Music]
thank you